today on the matt wall show squad member
corey bush gives a shockingly honest
answer when asked why
she uses private security even as she
calls for defunding the police
uh you should hear this and we'll play
today we'll talk about the lessons we
might learn from it also
cnn runs a story that unintentionally
reveals the psychological abuse that
some coveted panicked parents are
subjecting their children to it's worse
than you might think and ron desantis
again proves
why he should be the 2024 uh front
runner plus in our daily cancellation we
have a story about a trans youtuber
named chris chan that is so outrageous
that if i summarized it right now you
would think i was making it up so you'll
have to stick around to hear that
and much more today on the matte wall
[Applause] [Music]
show
these days you know a lot of us spend
way too much time staring at screens
i know that i certainly do although for
for a lot of us it's also part of our
job
where our job is contained within the
screen and so we have to stare at it
or if you're watching this show right
now uh you know you really have to stare
at the screen
you must so um the problem is though
that uh you know the blue light damages
our eyes and can lead to blurred vision
headaches dry watery eyes a lot of
people suffering from this because of
all this time
staring at screens and that's why you
need blue blocks blue blocks
was created to fix this problem block
out the damaging blue light
with high quality lenses unlike other
types of blue light glasses blue blocks
are evidence-based and made under optics
optic laboratory conditions in australia
the founders were unhappy with the
quality and lack of science behind
leading blue light blocking glasses
brands and so that's why they made blue
blocks
and the difference between them and some
other brands is that they actually work
they also have over 40 stylish frames
for every need
so you don't need to sacrifice uh the
style for the functionality you kind of
get both here
and they come in prescription
non-prescription and readers blue box is
also giving back in partnership with
restoring vision for each pair of blue
blocks glasses purchased they'll donate
a pair of reading glasses to someone in
need so go to
blue blocks dot com slash wall shoes
coupon con wall coupon code walls just
say 15
that's blueblox.com b l
o b-l-u-b-l-o-x dot com slash wall
should use coupon code walsh to save 15
off before we really begin today i must
again
harass you with some shameless
self-promotion if you have not yet
signed up for my email newsletter the
matt walsh report then please do
that immediately otherwise i'll have to
keep talking about it also
we have achieved some major milestones
just this week as i crossed 100 000
followers on instagram 600
000 followers on twitter and 800 000 on
facebook a few weeks ago these are
without a doubt
the greatest accomplishments of my life
which perhaps means that i have lived a
terribly sad
and pathetic life but be that as it may
make sure to follow me on all those uh
all those uh those platforms those three
platforms follow me on all platforms
everywhere
just follow me everywhere except please
don't follow me in real life or else
i'll be forced to
call the police speaking of the police
that provides us with a seamless
transition into our lead topic today
which revolves around
defund the police activist democratic
representative racist
shill abject [ __ ] and revolting
disgrace of a human being
corey bush she was you may recall most
recently seen in a makeshift
pretend homeless encampment surrounded
by
empty bags of oreos and fritos calling
for the cdc
to illegally seize private property from
middle-class landowners
after succeeding in that mission bush
appeared on cbs to celebrate
this further legal persecution of the
middle class
during the course of the interview the
subject turned to her advocacy for the
defund the police movement
and she was asked about a recent report
which seems to hint at some hypocrisy on
bush's part when it comes to this
before we get to our answer let me read
a little bit of this report from um this
is from fox news it says missouri
representative corey bush spent nearly
70 thousand dollars on private security
over the past three months
as she advocated for defunding the
police according to campaign filings
bush's campaign spent or sent 54 000
in payments between april 15th and june
28th for security services to
rs and t security consulting a new
york-based firm
with a mysterious online presence the
democrats campaign also paid 15 grand to
nathaniel davis for security services
and uh the 69 000 security payments
accounted for more than a third of
bush's
197 thousand dollars in campaign
expenditures during the second quarter
it's also nearly double what her
campaign spent on private security
during the first quarter of 2021
she's also spent tax money on private
security as well
now this just so you know
is a lot for someone to spend on private
security
even her fellow squad members have paid
only a fraction
of that total but she's spent more than
all of them combined a lot more
but whether she's forking over a lot or
literal or something in between the
greater point is that this woman seeks
to deprive
poor middle-class people of the safety
and security that she obviously feels
herself entitled to
that brings us to the cbs interview in
which cory bush was
blindsided when the anchors posed an
actual real question
asking her to explain the contrast
between her defund the police position
and her exorbitant personal security
expenditures you have to feel for bush a
little bit here because
she wasn't expecting someone on her own
team to put her on the spot like that so
she was obviously taken a little bit off
guard and yet her answer is extremely
revealing
and uh worth listening to almost in its
entirety so this this clip is a little
bit long but i think it's worth your
time let's take a listen
they would rather i die you would rather
me die is that what you want to see
you want to see me die you know because
that could be the alternative
so either i spent 70 000 on private
security over the last few months
and i'm here standing here standing now
and able to speak
able to help save 11 million people
from being evicted or i could possibly
have a death attempt on my life and
we're also talking about the same exact
people
who say horrible things about me who lie
to get to to build up their base and
then because they lie about me
i receive death threats i have private
security because my body
is worth being on this planet right now
i have private security
because they the white supremacists
racist narrative that they drive into
this country
the fact that they don't care that this
black woman that has put her life on the
line they can't match my energy first of
all
this black woman who's who puts her life
on the line
they don't care that my that i could be
taken out of here
they actually probably are okay with
that but this is the thing
i won't let them get that off you can't
get that off i'm going to make sure i
have security because i know
i have had attempts on my life and i
have too much work to do there are too
many people
that need help right now for me to allow
that so if
i end up spending 200 000 if i spend 10
10 10 more dollars on it you know what i
get to be here to
do the work so suck it up and defunding
the police has to happen
we need to defund the police and put
that money into social safety nets
because we're trying to save lives
my god what a [ __ ]
what a very stupid person they've
elected to congress there
she said attempts on her urban attempts
on her life so people have actually
tried to kill her and
and and the that's private because she
says that there's been attempts on her
life
and if it wasn't for the private
security she wouldn't be on this earth
right now so
she's saying that people have actually
come up and tried to kill her
and the private security had to step in
and save their life did
when did that happen i don't remember
hearing about that an actual
assassination
attempt seems like that would have made
the news i don't remember hearing
anything about that
but i don't doubt that corey bush gets
death threats if that's what she means
by now that's not the same thing as an
attempt on your life a threat is not the
same thing as an attempt
um although i don't deny that the i
don't i don't uh
doubt that those death threats happen
i'm also not
impressed by that fact frankly because
everybody on the public stage gets death
threats
um i get them i i've had crazed leftists
threatened to murder
me and my children i've had threats even
more graphic and gruesome than that
targeted not just at me but at my family
and my kids and i'm not even gonna
repeat them
i i could tell you that any time i've
run afoul especially of the blm mob in
particular
there's normally at least one person
from that crowd who will step up to send
me a message threatening to shoot me in
the face
now this is not a contest but the point
is that these democrats who allegedly
get death threats
cannot act as though they're special or
unique in that category it's certainly
bad
it's a bad thing for anyone to get death
threats it's a bad thing that nobody can
seem to voice an opinion in this country
publicly without
without having some mob of people from
one side or another
threatening to murder them for it and we
could have a conversation about that we
could talk about how we've
reached this point as a society and
and um how much of it can be blamed on
the casual anonymity afforded by the
internet i think a lot of it can be in
my opinion
but the conversation can't be fruitful
if it's been decided from the outset
that somehow it must all tie back to
white supremacy
and that's why almost no conversation in
this country is fruitful today because
it's decided from the outset
that white supremacy must be the answer
to every question
it's like trying to play a game of clue
if the rules stipulate that the murderer
always has to be
you know kernel mustard with a
candlestick in the kitchen it just it
doesn't work it doesn't go anywhere
now that aside the real issue here of
course is that corey bush believes that
she is deserving of a level of
protection and security
that the average family of nameless
faceless peons
does not warrant the only thing unusual
about
that is that she's so explicit about it
she sees no problem with standing in
front of a camera and saying yeah
my life is important because the world
needs me around
but the same doesn't apply for everyone
this is a common theme with the democrat
party and prominent leftists in general
we could run down a laundry list they
want to defund the police while still
utilizing private protection for
themselves
they want to ban guns while surrounding
themselves with armed men
they want you to reduce your carbon
footprint while using private jets and
living in lavish energy inefficient
houses
they extol the virtues of socialism
while reaping personal profits they tell
you to
wear a mask and socially distance while
throwing maskless parties for themselves
i mean the list goes on and i think
there are a couple of things for us to
understand about this
about these double standards one
is that the vision of life preached by
the leftist politician
is just that a vision a phantom
something lingering in the ether an
abstraction
nobody actually lives it nobody can live
it
this is different from what you find on
the right now it's true that plenty of
republicans are sniveling hypocrites
no question there are many examples that
come immediately to mind of a you know
for example a family values conservative
who lives a life behind the scenes which
would seem to indicate that he doesn't
value family at all least of all his own
family
but even so the basic vision of life
that conservatives promote or should
promote anyway
is one that certainly can be lived and
is lived
and has been lived it is practical
and attainable and it leads to real
happiness and fulfillment speaking just
for myself as a conservative
what i promote is is a family and
faith-centered life
where the home mother father children
lie at the foundation and society is
structured around protecting and
sustaining this foundational unit
and especially protecting the children
both physically and morally
this is not the kind of society we have
right now and many people don't live
this way
but we know that it is possible to have
this sort of society and it is possible
to live this way
because this was the way of western
civilization for countless centuries
before we came along
and screwed everything up now on the
left it's a different story
they say among other things they want to
dismantle the patriarchal nuclear family
they want to dismantle the traditional
rule of law by defunding and abolishing
the police
they want to abolish free market
capitalism they want to abolish any
sense of traditional morality abolish
biological sex abolish gender roles
entirely
turn away from modern technological
advancements which they say are
leading to a planetary cataclysm this is
not only a hideous plan for the future
and one which in attempting it can only
lead to despair it's also not really
possible
it's certainly not possible to have a
functioning society or live a
functioning life
while demolishing all of these things
which serve as the pillars of such a
society
and a life these leftists do not
live in a manner that is consistent with
their professed worldview
because their professed worldview is
objectively insane
and cannot actually be lived
so that's one thing to keep in mind the
other is that the hypocrisy the double
standard
the more for me less for you attitude
from corey bush
and her comrades is the point
she's not shy about it she's not upset
when we point it out the point
is that she is superior she is better
she is more important
her life is more valuable so when you
say hey corey you're acting like your
life is more valuable
she responds yeah thank you for noticing
now you're starting to get it she wants
you to see it
she wants it to seep into your
consciousness she wants you to come to
believe
that you really are something less than
her
you know when people um use the word
orwellian these days they're normally
referring to the book 1984 which was no
doubt prophetic in many ways
but a book that seems even more relevant
to our time is orwell's animal farm his
allegorical satire of communism
and someone on twitter reminds me of
this passage when the pigs who are
the communist leaders of the farm are
revealed to have been helping themselves
to better and more bountiful rations
than the other animals even as they
preach equality and everyone should get
the same and so on
one of the pigs to try to calm the mob
endeavors to explain
why they are entitled to more and better
and this is what he says he says quote
comrades you do not imagine i hope that
we pigs are doing this in a spirit of
selfishness and privilege
many of us actually dislike milk and
apples i dislike them myself
our whole object in taking these things
is to preserve our health
milk and apples this has been proven by
science comrades contain substances
absolutely necessary to the well-being
of a pig
we pigs are brain workers the whole
management and organization of this farm
depend on us
day and night we are watching over your
welfare it is for your sake that we
drink the milk
and eat those apples i mean that is
almost verbatim just take milk and
apples out and put private security in
it's almost exactly what cory bush said
it's for our sake that our bettors help
themselves to rights and privileges
that they seek to deny us that was the
message from the pigs on the farm
and it's the message from the pigs in
congress and they hope you
hear it and take it to heart
now let's get to our five headlines
well you guys know one of my favorite
sponsors uh i love talking about is
charity mobile and
why do i love charity mobile so much
because one of the reasons is
it's a matter of exhaustion i'm
exhausted by all these companies out
there
who um who hate me even if i even as i
give them money as a customer
they they hate me and they're they're
working against me they're using that
money to work against
our you know our cause in the culture
well that's not the case for charity
mobile charity mobile
is the pro-life phone company because
five percent of your monthly plan price
goes to the pro-life
pro family charity of your choice which
means that you can switch to a company
that shares your beliefs and won't
cancel or censor you for them
in fact they're going to support you for
them and
there's a lot of other great perks that
come with it because it's a great
service new activations and eligible
accounts get a free cell phone with free
activation and free shipping
you also get free usage alerts you get a
free app to monitor your usage and pay
your bills and much more
a lot of convenience there as well no
contracts no termination fees
no risk with a 30 day guarantee you also
get nationwide service on america's most
reliable network i've never had any
problems
with my charity mobile phone in terms of
service um so
you can turn everyday living into
effortless giving for the charity of
your choice
call them at
them online at 1-877-474-3662
uh by the way i want to thank everyone
for i talked yesterday about the this
situation that i'm in uh personal crisis
i'm in uh revolving around a dog and how
this pressure campaign that's being
waged against me by
by my wife and children
to get a dog and
many many comments many people leaving
comments sending me messages and emails
giving me advice and tips and
suggestions on like what kind of dog to
get i said that that
if i was going to get a dog would have
to be a dog that could provide some kind
of service to the family
we don't need another creature lying
around
to be taken care of if they're not
contributing everyone has to contribute
including um the we already have a cat
that does absolutely nothing for us
whatsoever
so a lot of suggestions and what i'm
like what kind of dog could fit that a
good family dog but also a dog that
could provide some protection be a good
guard dog
and what i am getting from taking all of
these pieces of advice and i did read a
lot of it
and what i'm getting from it is that
every dog you can name
is perfect for what i'm looking for but
also horrible for what i'm looking for
so that's what i'm getting from that
that's the dog owner advice that's
that's what i've discovered
every single dog is great but also
terrible
which is sort of what i already thought
so it's kind of confirming my priors i
guess
all right jen pasaki offered her
justification for biden
extending the eviction moratorium even
though he'd already said it wasn't legal
to do so
and uh there's there's really no good
answer she can give here because this
was
it's pretty straightforward he said i
can't do it it's illegal and then he did
it
but she makes an attempt here to explain
to wiggle her way out of this and here's
how that goes
after the president was clear that it
wasn't legal gene spurling was clear
that it wasn't legal is this a
roll the dice and see if it gets
challenged positioned
from an administration that may be doing
something it knows is not on legal
standing
well the president would not have
supported moving forward with any action
where he wasn't didn't feel there was uh
legal standing
and legal support uh we obviously don't
control what the courts do
uh and we we have uh of course seen what
the supreme court
decided and how they ruled which was not
related to public health as you well
know kellyanne was related to
the relationship between the landlord
and the renter
uh but the this is different in that it
is more targeted
uh it is focused on counties with higher
substantial case rates
to protect renters and and cdc
ultimately at site it decided to adopt
it i would also note that
the conditions have changed uh the rise
of the delta variant especially in
communities where
there are large numbers of unvaccinated
individuals where there are growing case
numbers
is certainly something that has raised
the alarm for us it has raised the alarm
for members of congress
and it has certainly uh added to the
need
to take this additional step ah okay
conditions have changed and that's why
conditions changed what they changed in
12 hours
they changed between the time when biden
said he couldn't do it it's illegal and
then when he did it
because we're talking about less than a
day in between those two
events they change what what changed
what exactly changed what are you
talking about
and then she also says this is targeted
and focused
it's a different eviction moratorium
because it's it's a targeted and focused
moratorium
even if it was
even if that was the case it still would
not be a legal justification
the supreme court just said you can't do
this
even if this was targeted in focus that
it only affected you know
15 of um of renters or something like
that
i don't care if it only affects one
percent the cdc doesn't have this
authority i don't care if it only
applies to
one renter in the entire country it's
simply authority the cdc does not have
but as it happens this targeted and
focused
policy applies to as i said yesterday
90 of the population
um i think it's something like 80
of us counties equaling 90 percent of
the population
targeted and focused right okay two
republican governors in the news
one bad one good so some yin and yang
balance here which is always nice
so we'll do bad first we'll save the
good for later um this is asa hutchinson
of arkansas who somehow manages to be
perhaps the olympist weakling in the
whole party which
of course is really saying something and
um
he hasn't done a lot good there's not
much that he's done that's been
worthwhile
um but at least one worthwhile thing he
did
was banning mask mandates in his state
it's like the one thing you can give
this guy credit for
and now he's saying he regrets that one
good thing he did
he feels bad about having done it let's
listen to that
i signed it for those reasons that our
cases are at a low point everything has
changed now
and yes in hindsight i wish that had not
become law
but it is the law and the only chance we
have is either to amend it or
uh for the courts to say that it has an
unconstitutional foundation oh
dear god what what
first of all you will never hear
a democrat ever say anything like that
can you think of an example prove them
wrong tell me i'm wrong
can you can you think of any example of
any democrat
at any position of power ever saying oh
yeah we you know i i did this thing and
i regret it
never happens it doesn't matter what it
is
even if it's a pi even if it's a a
democratic governor who put a policy in
place
that directly led to the deaths of
thousands of elderly people
as is the case in new york they will
defend that to their own death
they will defend that they will go down
swinging they will
never admit that it was a mistake
and yet in this case the one good thing
this useless sack of nothing has ever
done
he regrets
and his reason is well the case the the
cases had gone had gone down
did you not realize that the cases would
go back up
you idiot is that re so that's why you
passed
the ban on mask mandates
is because you thought the cases
wouldn't go back up
okay well i could i'm not an
epidemiologist
which these days i think makes me a
greater expert on on disease because of
how badly the epidemiologists have
failed but either way i'm not an
epidemiologist i could have told you
that
um with any virus
it's going to be it's going to be ebbs
and flows ebbs and flows and that's how
it's going to be
from here on out this is a virus that's
always going to be with us and the cases
are going to go up and the cases are
going to go down
fortunately deaths are staying
relatively steady because they're
because so many people in this country
are immune
um but yeah that that that's not a
surprise to me
so what was the conversation who told
this guy
hey governor we should pass this uh pass
this this law because uh
the the coving cases are never going to
go up again
and if you didn't think that covet cases
would ever go up again
then why pass the bill banning mask
mandates in the first place
the pressure for the mass mandates was
only going to come back when the cases
go back up
if you thought they would never go back
up then why did you need the bill
so it doesn't make any sense uh and he's
just
he cannot withstand any public pressure
from the media from the left at all he
will cave in an instant
and yet uh the fine people of arkansas
somehow elected this guy
that's my question for you that's a
sincere question
i don't follow arkansas politics that
closely i admit
so really i'm throwing this out there
for any arkansas voter who voted for
this guy what did you see in him
what what did you like about him exactly
what am i missing
and if i if it seems like i'm being a
little harsh on the hudson keep in mind
this is the same guy
who wouldn't sign a bill banning the
chemical castration of children
so what did you see him seeing him i'd
like to know
okay now let's go to the good ron
desantis all right a little bit of a
pallet cleanser here ronda sandus gave a
press conference yesterday
what a contrast between what you just
saw from asa hutchinson and this year
uh the press conference the whole thing
was great but i loved especially when we
get towards the end
speaking directly to biden let's uh
let's play this joe biden is taken to
himself to try to single out florida
over covid this is a guy who ran for
president saying he was going to quote
shut down the virus and what has he done
he's imported more virus from around the
world by having a wide open southern
border
you have hundreds of thousands of people
pouring across
every month and it's not just from
mexico in fact it's rarely from mexico
you have over a hundred different
countries where people are pouring
through
not only are they letting them through
they're then farming them out
all across our communities across this
country putting them on planes
putting them on buses do you think
they're being uh worried about covid for
that of course not
so he's facilitating who knows what new
variants are out there but i can tell
you whatever variants are around the
world
they're coming across that southern
border and so he's not shutting down the
virus
he's helping to facilitate it in our
country why don't you do your job
why don't you get this border secure and
until you do that
i don't want to hear a blip about covid
from you
thank you
there it is he's exactly right about the
border of course
that joe biden is inviting into the
country
hordes of infected people and just
letting them in
letting them in to spread the the virus
it's
you can look at a map of where kovit
is is spreading the most right now and
where the where the biggest spikes and
cases are
and wouldn't you know i mean what a
coincidence that
so many of these big spikes are
happening down south near the border
crazy it's like you know i i don't know
again
again not an epidemiologist but it just
seems like you're
opening up the border you're inviting
people in we know that hundreds and
thousands of these people are infected
with covid
and then and then around the areas where
they're coming in we're seeing spikes in
cases it's like you might actually draw
some sort of connection i don't know
so he's exactly right of course about
everything that he said um
joe biden is facilitating the spread of
the virus
and he knows that's what he's doing to
the extent that he knows
anything anymore to the extent that he
knows what he's doing at all in general
in life
to the extent that he that he knows that
he's eating breakfast while he eats it
he knows what he's doing down
on the border he's doing it
intentionally and uh ronda sanchez is
exactly right about that and this is
this is what we need from republicans
again the contrast between asa
hutchinson utterly ineffectual
useless and then ron desantis who is
really getting things done as a governor
you don't play defense the other
contrast here is asa hutchinson playing
defense
oh no i'm sorry i didn't mean it you're
putting the shield up hiding behind the
podium practically
he was all but ducking behind the podium
don't yell at me i'm sorry
um that's defense whereas ron desantis
is going right after them
and doing it in meaningful ways
which is why ron desantis
should be considered our front one
runner for 2024.
i mean yeah it's still still far away he
hasn't officially announced
that he's running for president yet if
he does run
listen every time i say this i know it
upsets a certain portion of the audience
who don't want to hear it but um
at this point looking forward to what is
a likely scenario
in the republican primaries for 2024
where you've got a whole field of people
and behind that field is at front
donald trump and ron desantis
there is no reason
to support a 78 year old
donald trump over ron desantis in 2024
except just that you're invested in a
personality cult
like at this point assuming that both of
those guys
are in the running and are an option for
voters
if you're going with trump it's it's
because you're in the personality cult
there cannot be
any other reason there really can't
78 years old he's going to turn he's as
old as biden he will be as old as biden
when he gets to 2024.
so you're giving him a second shot in
his 80s
to accomplish some things that frankly
look trump to accomplish some things
that trump never even came
close to accomplishing the first time
didn't even try
even simple things like drain the swamp
can we be honest with each other trump
did not drain the swamp
didn't try to made no attempt
in fact he surrounded himself with the
swamp
and listened to them for four years
did their bidding that's that's the
truth
he had trump had very little interest in
in the act of
actually governing
and also is trump's two biggest flaws
okay
little interest in the actual act of
governing the the work of governing
especially the boring stuff
the stuff you're doing behind the scenes
where you're really governing
little interest in doing that and um
also
trump always cared deeply what people
said about him
and how they and how they felt about him
and so he spent the entire four years
defending himself
personally and he's also on the other
side of it he's susceptible to flattery
so if you flattered him he would let you
into the circle and listen to you
um ronda sanders doesn't have those
flaws not saying he's flawless he's a
politician they've i mean all people
have laws politicians especially
but those are not flaws that he has he
is very interested in the act of
governing he's very good at it
and he doesn't seem to be he doesn't
seem to really care what anyone says
and there's no evidence that you can
flatter your way into his heart and
manipulate him that way
so almost all of the good points of
trump are shared by
desantis and most of the bad points are
not shared
and he's a lot younger um and he's a
rising star
so to me it's an easy decision i i just
i that i would like for someone to make
a case for me for trump over desantis
that goes beyond personality cult stuff
if you could do it i'd be interested to
hear all right
let's play this for you also um here's
some more good news
if you're a woman and you've been out of
the workforce and you're thinking about
returning to the workforce
meghan markle is there to mentor you so
let's uh let's listen to her make that
pitch because i'm turning 40 i'm asking
40 friends to donate 40 minutes of their
time
to help mentor a woman who's mobilizing
back into the workforce
over two million women in the u.s alone
and tens of millions around the world
have lost their jobs due to covid
and i think if we all do it and all
commit 40 minutes to some sort of active
service we can create a ripple effect
you in yes times 40. 40 40 40 and then
40 times i say yes
is it okay if i still
do it in the hat i wouldn't expect
anything less
thanks friend bye friend
cheers see you at 50.
okay so i just one really quick question
here
i'm posing a lot of questions on the
show today here's another question
if you're looking for mentorship
um in returning to the workforce why
would you turn to a woman who's never
had a job in her life
she's never been in the workforce she
knows nothing about it
right now what is she is she is she a
working professional
professional what is her profession
meghan markle's profession right now is
being meghan markle
that's her whole profession
uh but yeah she she'll she'll offer you
some
some helpful advice i'm sure all right
finally before we get to reading the
comments i've had this clip for a few
days and
uh that i've wanted to play we'll play
it now the bbc
interviewed a sports scientist about the
issue of men and women's sports that
obviously has been a big issue
especially with the the olympics
and laurel hubbard showing up as a male
although he's a male competing against
the women in weightlifting he
he flunked out and embarrassed himself
but even so
um that's why it's been in the news so
they brought on
ross tucker who's a sports scientist
and he had an opinion about all of this
that has proven to be very offensive
to lots of people at least to the sorts
of people who get offended by basic
reality but here it is
the problem is that there's an asymmetry
where once testosterone has done its job
and viewers will know what that job is
it's basically the development of male
characteristics which we see
so prominently during puberty and
adolescence so we're talking muscle bone
decreased body fat increased heart and
lung size all of which adds up to
strength and performance
advantages once those are laid down by
testosterone's effects you can't undo
them simply by
lowering the testosterone level and
there are now ample studies that have
demonstrated this and so therefore the
conclusion is that
even the suppression of testosterone as
is required
leaves behind a considerable residual
advantage
that then means it's unfair to cross
into the women's sport category
needless to say i don't have to tell you
that he is being condemned
as a bigot and a transphobe for all of
that
meanwhile it's 100
undeniably true those are simply
scientific facts there's no debate
there's nothing to argue about it's not
an arguable proposition
if you disagree with it you're just
wrong
and you don't understand basic human
biology
the only thing he's wrong about in fact
he said one wrong thing in that whole uh
clip that was
that was he said one thing the whole
clip that was incorrect
when he said oh well viewers will
understand what testosterone does no
the viewers won't understand that a lot
of viewers don't so you're wrong about
that you
you have assumed too much i'm afraid
because lots of people especially on the
left they seem to think that um
well they'll say either that
testosterone doesn't make a difference
at all
or that if you're dealing with someone
where their testosterone levels have
been suppressed
maybe through drugs or something well
then you've even the score
except that when we talk about the
biological differences between men and
women
testosterone is just one small piece of
the puzzle
there are hundreds literally hundreds of
other differences
biologically and as he points out
by the time you start suppressing the
testosterone
especially for grown men who in like
their 30s decide that they want to
identify as women
the testosterone has already done it as
he said it's already done its job it's
already
it has already created these differences
there's no way to undo that
you could take a drug you could get fake
implants
you can mutilate your genitals but the
biological
advantages are there and they're not
going anywhere
simple scientific facts that's it but
you're also dealing with
the people who for them scientific facts
mean
absolutely nothing because their
feelings of course override
all of that as we talked about yesterday
in a blatant authoritarian move
mayor bill de blasio just mandated that
businesses in new york
um require proof of vaccination from all
prospective customers and also employees
it's just kind of shocking how
transparent the left is in this show of
tyranny and it's time americans
stood up and used one of the shortest
words in
in the english language and also one of
the most important no because
authoritarianism has now come to
america's shores and if we don't do
something
we're going to pay the price and that's
why there's no better time to pick up
ben shapiro's new book the authoritarian
moment
which talks all about this
authoritarianism where we are now where
it came from the history of it and also
what we can do
about it which is the most important
thing so go pick up the authoritarian
moment now
available at amazon barnes noble or any
other major bookseller
all right let's go now to reading the
youtube comments um
i'll start with this someone deeply hurt
my feelings yesterday if you listen to
the
comments section by saying that i need
to talk about different topics so the
producer put up a question in the
comments
asking if if i should
discuss different topics or if they like
the show as it is
and here are some of the answers to that
question um
matt is on it don't change a thing matt
is my favorite daily
wire host by far keep up the good work
matt is excellent
i think what's covered in the show is
great i just want him to cover what
interests him
well there it is this curated sample of
people
have spoken um and by the way though
it is it is like it is true that i that
i cover up what interests me
and even if it doesn't always interest
you you maybe could take some solace in
knowing that i actually do
care about the issues i discuss and i
believe what i'm saying
uh and i'm not going to talk about
anything that
i don't care about or don't believe in
you'll notice that there there can often
be
huge stories that everyone else is
talking about
big you know headline news
that i won't talk about at all and the
answer is i just don't care about them
and i won't even pretend to care
um so you know that at least if you hear
it on this show
what you're hearing me talk about i
actually care about these things and i
believe what i'm saying
and that might be a low bar but i can
tell you that
in the media not a lot of people meet
that bar
whatever show you're listening to for
many for many shows
you're hearing people say a lot of
things they don't necessarily believe
and talk about topics they don't really
care about
all right um moose chuckles says matt am
i allowed to watch this show without
being vaccinated damn you moose chuckle
you're endangering all of our lives
banned from the show obviously ron says
come on matt dogs are great our dog is a
pet and i tell him that his only job in
the house is to let people pet
him cats won't even let you pet them i i
get that i just
he's gonna need to carry more weight
okay
than that i i have uh
it's not that i'm anti-animal or
anything i just i have i guess i have a
more old-fashioned view
of everything in life but also animals
where it's it's fine to have an animal
in the home or as
but they got to do something they got to
contribute in some way
in some tangible way i don't think
that's much that's too much to ask
um cool papa j magic says i know i'm not
supposed to cry as a man but i teared up
just a little bit to see that woman so
happy to represent our beautiful
country and i will allow that that i
will allow will
previously i said i think there are six
reasons acceptable reasons for a man to
cry
i'll add number seven i'll give you that
you're welcome
um coming for you says
matt walsh slowly becoming my favorite
he's really easy to relate to
slowly you say why only slowly
you're banned from the show uh john says
i'm a landlord i own five properties
have mortgages on all of them the only
thing that's keeping me afloat is the
four tenants that pay on time
the only one that doesn't pay is taking
away all of my profits
so more some more stories like that from
landlords see the thing is
this is one of the good stories in
comparison to the others
because this is someone at least john
like you're staying afloat
and that's it isn't good but compared to
many other landlords i've
this how bad it's gotten that that
qualifies as a good story a success
story right now
and maybe john you could confirm this
i'm assuming is that you own five
properties you're a landlord
i think there are many people who maybe
especially those who don't own any
property at all
and they hear that they think oh you own
five properties you must be a
multi-millionaire
you're basically bill gates
but in fact you don't have to be a
multi-millionaire to own five properties
because the whole point this is an
investment and uh the
part of the strategy here is that you're
renting them out
and so that you don't have to pay five
mortgages
so maybe john maybe you can i'm assuming
i'm guessing that even though you own
five properties you're not a
multi-millionaire
um josiah says if i win the backstage
pass do i get to sit on sweet daddy
walsh's knee and get a picture
hopefully this comment creep creeps you
out enough to abandon the whole
daddy walsh thing
it does creep me out but i am stubborn
so that that all
you've done here is just ensure that i
will refer to myself that way even more
so this
you had this coming from your sweet
daddy
it is pretty bad i don't know how long
much longer i can sustain this
well the world has gone completely crazy
i think we all know that
but the good news is that you could get
a respite from that
kind of an oasis in the storm by coming
here daily wire studios
and hanging out with us with cigars and
whiskey
backstage watching an episode of of
backstage with all of us
uh you could tour the studios you could
tour the offices you get a great swag
bag of merch
i really wish that that wasn't swag bag
of merch
you can get some merchandise some items
um and you can watch us debate on the
show live
but you're you're going to want to hurry
because there's not a lot of time to uh
get an opportunity to do this this is
your last chance so if you're not a
member yet head to dailywire.com
backstage and enter code backstage at
checkout for 25
off your membership and you also get
automatically entered to win one of the
coolest trips you'll ever take again
uh this is your last chance to do it so
make sure you do it now also there's no
question
in my mind that every american deserves
to wake up to the facts
and we're here to make sure that happens
at the daily wire that's why our newest
podcast the morning wire has been
topping the apple and spotify charts
since its recent release because it's
the only daily news podcast that values
your time and the truth
and while we're working overtime to
bring you the news that you need to know
we need your help to make sure the facts
get out to more and more people so
subscribe now to morning wire on apple
spotify or wherever you listen to
podcasts and make sure to leave a
five-star review
if you like what you hear now let's get
to our daily cancellation
[Music]
now fair warning to those who complain
that the subjects i cover on this show
are often too dark and disturbing
if you feel that way you're not going to
like this segment
and i say that in order to give you time
to bail out now
if you want for those who remain here's
a headline that sounds like something
that a mentally ill babylon b
writer might come up with in the middle
of a lsd induced psychotic break
here's the headline trans youtuber chris
chan
39 is listed as female in police report
and will
will be jailed with women um despite
arrest for raping her dementia sufferer
mother
79. now unfortunately although there is
indeed plenty of mental illness involved
in this story it is not satire
an apparently well-known youtube
personality and web comic creator
was allegedly caught on tape admitting
to raping his own elderly mother
and because this monster now claims to
be a woman he is being housed with
actual women
in a women's prison the daily mail has
more
though i warn you that the details are
extremely difficult to stomach
here's what it says transgender youtuber
chris chan 39 was identified as female
by police will be housed with women
despite being biologically male
after she was arrested for raping her
mother
the vlogger and artist who goes by
christine weston chandler was arrested
after leaked phone calls allegedly
revealed her admitting to raping her
mother 79 who suffers from dementia
chandler's biologically male but came
out as transgender at the end of 2014.
chandler's arrest came just days after a
phone call was leaked on an instant
messaging platform
on which a person believed to be
chandler seemingly admitted to having
sex with her elderly mother who is
believed to have dementia
during the eight minute conversation
chandler apparently tells a friend that
it was her mother barbara
who made the first move leading the two
to kiss according to audiophile
uh to the audio file which newsweek
reported chandler allegedly claimed she
approached the situation with
care and caution after years of
harboring sexual feelings towards her
mother
and even having dreams of having sex
with her
she was partially confused at one point
but then she came around obviously
chandler's allegedly heard saying on the
call
as the call continues the person said to
be chandler says that she and her mother
now have a routine where they have sex
every third night
and that her mother enjoys it
that's as far as i could possibly go
there you'll notice how the daily mail
has taken great care to ensure that they
respect the pronouns of this alleged
rapist
newsweek yahoo news the new york post
every other media outlet that's reported
on the story
they've all done the same a man's
feelings must still be respected even
after he sexually assaults his own
mother
it would seem never mind the fact that
chris chan
is not only a deviant rapist allegedly
but also
clearly insane i pulled his most recent
youtube video before his arrest to give
you an idea
and not that you probably needed any
convincing about his dire mental state
but
uh here it is anyway watch listen here
and listen good i have told y'all and
kept it going
time and time again but y'all keep
putting it on put it on
but my little point generation five
is cancelled g4
friendship is magic needs it's five
more seasons it needs to go on to season
14.
now this is the last
straw it costs for the good and safety
of this timeline you need to get that
pulled off of shelves in amazon stores
or wherever else
oh i can stop it there um so you get the
idea
as best i can well you probably don't
get the idea at all as best as i can
tell he's yelling at hasbro about my
little pony
which is yet more confirmation from my
position that adults who watch cartoons
are weird
probably not this weird but weird and
yet somehow we're supposed to believe
that the self-identification of this
raving lunatic rapist
allegedly is a serious and meaningful
insight and not just another of his
deranged hallucinations
many people on the internet certainly
believe that which is why social media
in the aftermath of his arrest and the
reporting on the story
has have largely been more upset at the
people who misgender
chris chan than they are at chris chan
for sexually violating his
elderly mother more importantly the
court system
takes this delusional predator seriously
to the point of housing him in a prison
with
actual women and by the way a large
portion of the women in any prison
are going to be sexual abuse survivors
and and now they're going to be locked
in a cell with a large
unstable accused rapist this is
certainly a violation of the
constitutional protections
against cruel and unusual punishment and
it's even more certainly a violation of
basic common sense and human decency
but here's what makes all this even more
disturbing
if it's possible for it to get more
disturbing
millions of americans those on the
ideological left
do not possess the moral or intellectual
framework to object
to most aspects of this story
they cannot object and do not object to
a male
sex predator being housed with women and
he is not the only male sex predator to
be housed with women
in women's prisons this is happening
across the country
and that's bad enough on its own but
they also
can't really object even to incest in
and of itself
now in this case the victim has dementia
which means that she cannot consent
which means everyone agrees that it's a
horrific crime and yet if it weren't for
the dementia
then the leftist worldview would say
that it is simply a choice that two
people who love each other have made
and it isn't hurting anyone and we have
no room to judge their lifestyle
it's true that most leftists are not at
the point where they're going to openly
defend
consensual incest but their worldview
leads to that conclusion
inevitably inescapably everything they
say about sexuality
lays the groundwork they have no basis
to object to incest
if it's consensual and and they know it
they have no basis to object to any
sexual activity or lifestyle
at all as long as it passes the consent
test
now this one doesn't and so they're
saved from having to defend the most
revolting aspect of this story
but they still have to and do defend the
rest of it
what do we make of that how do we go
forward as a country knowing
that when half of us hear a story about
a man
who rapes his elderly mother and is sent
to a women's prison
we can only object to part of it and
even then the objection is qualified and
conditional
well i'm not sure that we do
go forward as a country ultimately the
chasm between us
is vast and deep and and cannot be
traversed
there is no middle ground or compromise
between the two sides
we can barely see each other across the
divide
and all we can hear is unintelligible
shouting
which is why all anyone does anymore is
shout
because we are so far apart
and that's why literally everyone
involved in the story
is of course i don't think i need to say
it
canceled but the good news
well i wish i could end on good news but
i'm not sure there is any good news we
could pull
from all of that you can go somewhere
else for your
your your portion of good news for the
day um what i can give out
with this story are cancellations and i
certainly hand them out
with uh with a vengeance and we'll leave
it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens
production manager pavel vadasky the
show was edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 2021.
john bickley here daily wire editor in
chief wake up every morning with our new
show
morning wire on today's episode we speak
to dr marty mccary about whether mask
and vaccine mandates are backed up by
the evidence
backlash builds against andrew cuomo and
an olympic athlete flees belarus
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire